der unkrautvernichter glyphosat ist ein
thema das sich viele von euch gewünscht
haben denn es ist ein klassischer fall
von wem soll ich jetzt noch glauben
ständig hört man völlig widersprüchliche
dinge krebs durch glyphosat feier soll
us kläger 80 millionen dollar zahlen
dpa hält glyphosat für nicht
krebserregend ist glyphosat doch
krebserregend und auch wenn man den
schlagzeilen auf den grund geht und
artikel für artikel sorgfältig
durchliest bleibt man ziemlich ratlos
zurück denn wert wirklich verstehen will
der muss wohl oder übel in die
wissenschaft reinschauen und zwar
richtig ins detail ging wer hat schon
zeit für sowas richtig wir also freunde
der sonne wohl durch einen tee macht es
euch gemütlich wir steigen jetzt richtig
durch fangen wir vorne an clueso saat
ist ein unkrautvernichtungsmittel und
zwar das meistgenutzte der welt strebt
man es auf pflanzen sterben die pflanzen
ab das ist praktisch wenn man zum
beispiel bahnschienen billig und
effektiv von bewuchs frei halten möchte
aber ganz besonders praktisch ist es für
die landwirte 90 prozent des weltweit
genutzten glyphosat wird in der
landwirtschaft eingesetzt mann sprühte
es zum beispiel auf die äcker bevor man
sät um vorab alle unkräuter zu entfernen
damit man eben platz hat für das was man
anbauen möchte mehr infos zur glyphosat
und seiner verwendung findet ihr in
unserem chance erster link in der video
beschreibung was viele aufgrund der
aktuellen berichte wundern wird ein
grund für den erfolg von glyphosat waren
die guten bewertungen seiner
unschädlichkeit die wirkung von
glyphosat beruht darauf dass es einem
anderen stoff ähnlich sieht nämlich dem
vostro idol privat deswegen bindet es in
pflanzen an ein enzym das normalerweise
phosphor in uri waadt bindet das enzym
wird dadurch quasi verstopft und kann
nicht weiter arbeiten dadurch kommt ein
ganzer stoffwechsel weg zum erliegen
nämlich der sogenannte shi qi mag wie
die pflanzen ist dieser stoffwechselweg
lebenswichtig wir menschen hingegen
haben den gar nicht deswegen ist
glyphosat für uns verhältnismäßig und
schädlich aber natürlich wird alles
irgendwann giftig der man sich nur genug
davon rein knallt die dosis macht das
gift aber bei glyphosat ist diese dosis
eben ganz schön hoch diese
relative unschädlichkeit wurde von
verschiedenen behörden weltweit auch
immer wieder bestätigt bis im jahre 2015
die internationale agentur für
krebsforschung die ihren gericht zu
glyphosat vorlegte mit dem urteil
wahrscheinlich krebserregend für den
menschen jetzt gibt es aber noch viele
weitere behörden die solche sachen
prüfen und beurteilen und kripo saat
wurde auch von einigen anderen behörden
geprüft und die kommen alle zu dem
schluss dass glyphosat nicht
krebserregend sei eine dieser behörden
war die europäische behörde für
lebensmittelsicherheit fsa die für die
eu zuständig ist bei diesem bericht war
das deutsche bundesinstitut für
risikobewertung das bfr federführend wie
kann das sein
wie kann es sein dass die ihr rc zu
einem scheinbar völlig anderen ergebnis
kommt als zb fsb wenn man sich damit
beschäftigt da fällt einem als erstes
auf das ist eine fucking schlammschlacht
ist beiden behörden ist vorgeworfen
worden beeinflusst bis hin zu bestochen
worden zu sein entweder von fünf
herstellern die natürlich mit hilfe sagt
sehr viel geld verdienen oder von us
anwaltskanzlei auf der anderen seite die
die hersteller auf milliardensummen
verklagen also ich habe einige falsche
anklagen gesehen und eine menge menge
spekulation wahrscheinlich kriege ich
nach diesem video ein paar böse
nachrichten von beiden seiten weil ich
mich an der jeweiligen spekulation nicht
beteilige aber das möchte ich auch gar
nicht muss ich auch nicht denn die
gutachten der beiden behörden sind ja
wissenschaftlich begründet worden nur
damit das klar ist sowohl ja rc als auch
fsa bfr sind seriöse wissenschaftlich
arbeitende institut schauen wir uns mal
die daten lagern jetzt gedruckt
wenn wir herausfinden wollen ob etwas
krebserregend ist dann gibt es leider
nicht so etwas wie ein krebs mikroskop
wo wir einfach eine substanz darunter
liegen können anschauen und dann sofort
erkennen ja total krebserregend
stattdessen müssen wir ganz viele
puzzleteile sammeln um am ende ein
gesamtbild zu erhalten
wichtiges puzzleteil liefern
beobachtungsstudien auch genannt
epidemiologie da gibt es verschiedene
studiendesigns bei case control studien
nimmt man zwei gruppen einmal eine case
gruppe das sind dann zum beispiel
landwirte die krebs haben und die
vergleichbar mit der kontrollgruppe das
sind dann zum beispiel landwirte die
keinen krebs haben aber in alter
lebensstil so weiter möglichst gleich zu
der ersten gruppe sind und dann versucht
man herauszufinden wie viel post die
beiden gruppen in ihrem leben oder in
den letzten jahrzehnten abbekommen haben
solche case control studien haben
folgendes ergeben
menschen mit einem speziellen krebs dem
sogenannten non hodgkin lymphom haben in
ihrem leben mehr kripo saat abbekommen
als die gesunde vergleichsgruppe diese
studien sprechen also dafür dass
glyphosat die krebsart non hodgkin
lymphom begünstigt aber case control
studien haben einen grundlegenden
schwachpunkten kennen wir auch schon von
den handys genannten recall bayers sagen
wir ich habe krebs und werde im rahmen
einer case control studie befragt wie
oft ich mein handy benutzt habe in den
letzten jahren
jetzt habe ich vielleicht schon mal
gehört dass handystrahlung krebs
irgendwie zusammenhängt und das führt
dazu dass ich mich viel stärker daran
erinnere wie oft ich mein handy benutzt
habe als jemand aus der kontrollgruppe
dasselbe gilt natürlich auch für
glyphosat und krebs allein dieser
erinnerungs bei ist kann schon zu
unterschied zwischen den gruppen für
dann gibt es noch kohortenstudien wo man
menschen über jahre oder jahrzehnte
hinweg begleitet und beobachtet konnten
studien sind grundsätzlich aufwendiger
aber bei face mäßig häufig vorkommenden
krankheiten wie zum beispiel dem non
hodgkin lymphom sind sie deutlich
aussagekräftiger als case control
studien eine solche kohortenstudie ist
die agricultural health study seit 1993
werden über 50.000 landwirte aus north
carolina beobachtet unter anderem geben
sie an wieviel glyphosat sie benutzten
in dieser kurorten studie war bisher
kein statistisch signifikanter
zusammenhang zu sehen
zwischen glyphosat und irgendeine
krebsart auch nicht nur hodgkin lymphom
allerdings war diese erklärte hellster
die zum zeitpunkt der bewährt
noch nicht abgeschlossen und so sagten
beide behörden
die studie ist einfach noch nicht lange
genug gelaufen deswegen können wir einen
zusammenhang zwischen glyphosat und
krebs zu diesem zeitpunkt noch nicht
sicher ausschließen
die studie läuft zu diesem zeitpunkt
immer noch aber es gibt inzwischen etwas
neuere ergebnisse die auch er auf
entwarnung hinweisen die findet ihr auch
in unseren kinos
also unterm strich waren die
beobachtungsstudie mitmenschen zur
zeitpunkt der bewertung schlicht und
einfach wenig aufschlussreich was machen
wir jetzt
wir müssen uns ein weiteres puzzleteil
anschauen tierversuche bei denen tiere
und auch zehn versuchen kommt jetzt in
dem den eigentlichen ergebnissen noch
eine weitere interessante frage ins
spiel nämlich wer hat die studien
eigentlich bezahlt es gibt natürlich
unabhängige studien die von unabhängigen
wissenschaftlern an unis oder
forschungsinstituten durchgeführt werden
aber bei schifffahrt gibt es auch einige
studien die von der industrie
durchgeführt oder beauftragt wurden da
kann man sich natürlich denken moment
mal wie soll ich denn bitte einer studie
glauben die von kws saat hersteller
finanziert wurde andererseits muss ein
mittelweg lüchow saat natürlich erst mal
zugelassen werden und die hersteller
müssen nun einmal selbst dafür sorgen
dass alle notwendigen tests für diese
zulassung durchgeführt werden und das
natürlich auch richtig na also seine
forschung ist ja teuer und warum sollten
hier steuergelder verwendet werden wenn
irgendein konzern eine zulassung
beantragt deswegen ist in der praxis so
jeder weiß es hier ein
interessenkonflikt gibt und deswegen
muss man dem ganzen mit kontrolle und
strengen regeln begegnen also es gibt
strenge auflagen zur dokumentation und
durchführung um eben so was wie eine
fälschung zu vermeiden zum zeitpunkt der
bewertungen gab es nur drei unabhängige
studien die untersuchten ob die post bei
nagetieren krebs auslösen kann zwei
dieser drei studien wurden sowohl von
der rc als auch von der fsa als zu
schlecht aus notiert zu diesen
schlechten studien zählt übrigens auch
die berüchtigte studie aus der
arbeitsgruppe von sera lee nie die
leider bis heute als angeblicher beleg
im netz herumgeistert die einzige
unabhängige studie die übrig blieb war
diese
und sie fand keine hinweise dass
glyphosat in raten krebs auslösen würde
da waren sich auch beide behörden einig
nur eine studie reicht natürlich nicht
um eine bewertung abzugeben der
knackpunkt liegt also innerhalb der
restlichen studie der industrie
finanzierten studien ich sag das deshalb
denn wenn man sich im netz informiert
bekommt man manchmal den eindruck als
würde die irc sich ausschließlich
unabhängige studien anschauen
die fsa dafür industrie studie aber ganz
so einfach ist es auch hier wieder nicht
ist da mal was wahres dran
zulassungsbehörden schauen sich alle
verfügbaren studien an unabhängige sowie
industrie finanziert die er als hingegen
sagt bei uns läuft alles maximal
transparent deswegen benutzen wir für
unsere bewertung nur studien die
öffentlich zugänglich sind öffentlich
zugänglich dazu gehören natürlich die
unabhängigen studie die industrie
finanzierten studien werden meistens
nichts veröffentlicht und deswegen auch
von der er erzählt nicht berücksichtigt
aber in manchen fällen sind diese
industrie daten dann doch öffentlich
zugänglich nämlich dann wenn irgendeine
andere unabhängige behörde diese daten
geprüft und in ihrem bericht dann
ausreichend detailliert wiedergibt und
veröffentlicht in solchen fällen
berücksichtigt die ihr als sie also auch
industrie und auftrag studien aber beide
behörden betrachten tatsächlich
insgesamt verschiedene studien bzw
die fsa das bfr beziehen mehr industrie
finanzierte studien mit ein und das ist
tatsächlich ein grund für die
verschiedenen bewertungen aber auch das
ist noch nicht die ganze antwort wir
müssen uns die studienergebnisse genauer
anschauen es gibt vier langzeit studien
mit mäusen die im zentrum dieser
bewertung stehen bei diesen studien
wurde den mäusen anderthalb bis zwei
jahre lang privat ins futter gemischt in
diesen studien gab es nun statistisch
signifikante ergebnisse dass glyphosat
krebs auslösen könnte aber die behörden
waren sich nicht einig darüber wie diese
statistisch signifikanten ergebnisse zu
deuten sind und das mag einige
verwundern denn
statistik und zahlen müssten ja für sich
sprechen würde man meinen was gibt es da
schon zu deuten das wird schnell klar
wenn wir verstehen was statistische
signifikanz genau bedeutet sehr wichtige
lehren einheit statistische signifikanz
wird leider so oft falsch verstanden
theoretisch könnte ich bei jedem
ergebnis in der wissenschaft behaupten
war bestimmt nur zufall
das kann man so rein
erkenntnistheoretische mit absoluter
sicherheit ausschließen aber man kann
einen statistischen test machen der
berechnet wie hoch die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist dass es nur
zufall war
vereinfacht gesagt sagen wir machen
jetzt eine glyphosat emmaus studie und
es kommt raus die eine maus gruppe die
mit glyphosat hat ein bisschen mehr
krebs als die andere ohne prüfe sagt
dann müssen wir uns fragen wie
wahrscheinlich ist es dass dieser
unterschied nur eine zufällige
schwankungen ist klar je
unwahrscheinlicher desto
aussagekräftiger ist das ergebnis
sprechen nun von einem statistisch
signifikanten ergebnis denn diese
wahrscheinlichkeit mindestens so klein
ist wie die wahrscheinlichkeit mit einem
20 seitigen würfel eine eins zu würfeln
doch eins ist klar je öfter ich würfel
desto höher ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass irgendwann der einst dabei ist wenn
ich jetzt bei einer studie schauer
unterscheiden sich die nieren oder
scheinen sich die leben dann schaue ich
mir einmal nur die männchen an und
einmal nur die weibchen und mache jedes
mal einen statistischen test dann ist
das so als würde ich jedes mal erneut
würfeln anders gesagt wenn ich in vielen
studien für viele organe testen ob
irgendeine bestimmte krebsart häufiger
auftritt dann steigt mit jedem test die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass irgend eine
zufällige schwankungen statistisch
signifikant wird also wichtige tekom
message ein statistisch signifikantes
ergebnis ist nicht automatisch so
aussagekräftig wie es dieser ausdruck
vermuten lässt umso schwieriger ist es
jetzt für die ganzen gutachter und
behörden die müssen jetzt beurteilen ob
so ein statistisch signifikant ergebnis
wirklich durchfahrt verursacht wurde
oder ob es nicht doch eine zufällige
schwankungen ist die bei so vielen tests
gar nicht so überraschend wäre schauen
wir mal in die ergebnisse dieser film
aus studien dann werdet ihr selbst sehen
dass ich damit meine
die vier verschiedenen farben stehen für
die vier verschiedenen studien
ein punkt ist jeweils eine gruppe von
circa 50 mäusen die x-achse zeigt uns
welche glyphosat dosis sie jeweils im
futter hatten
die y-achse zeigt uns wie viel prozent
dieser mäuse einen tumor hatten und zwar
so genannte maligne lymphome also tumore
der lymphdrüsen erste wichtige info
keiner der kripo saat gruppen
unterscheidet sich statistisch
signifikant von der kontrollgruppe ohne
glyphosat anders gesagt die abweichung
von 0 milligramm glyphosat ist nicht
groß genug dass sie nicht auch zufällig
sein könnte aber zweite wichtige info
für zwei dieser studien ist der trend
signifikant dh wir sehen hier eine dosis
wirkungs beziehung das heißt der
kurvenverlauf sieht irgendwie so aus
also je mehr krise desto mehr krebs das
heißt auch hier kann man einen
statistischen test machen um
herauszufinden wie wahrscheinlich ist es
dass so ein trend
rein zufällig ist und wenn die
wahrscheinlichkeit klein genug ist dann
sprechen wir von einem signifikanten
trend so einen signifikanten trend haben
wir bei dieser studie hier bis auf
diesen ausreißer sieht es so aus wie
eine dosis wirkungs beziehung allerdings
gab die gfk zu bedenken dass diese
höchste dosis doch sehr hoch war sie
sagt wenn eine krebserregende wirkung
nur bei einer akut giftigen dosis zu
sehen ist kann das ein grund dafür seien
diese substanz nicht als krebserregend
einzustufen denn eine akut giftige dosis
kann zellen im gewebe töten wodurch neue
zellen nachwachsen was zu wucherungen
führen kann was wiederum in krebs
ausarten kann dieser effekt tritt erst
auf wenn ich in einen stark giftigen
bereich kommen es gibt also einen
stellenwert und wenn nicht unterliege
gibt es keine krebsgefahr
und weil quasi alles giftig ist wenn ich
nur eine gewisse dosis
welche gibt es kaum eine substanz auf
der welt bei der dieser effekt nicht
auftreten würde versteht ihr anders ist
das bei substanzen die grundlegend
krebserregend sind wie zum beispiel dna
schädigende substanzen wie tabakrauch
die haben keinen schwellenwert also wenn
die niedrig dosiert sind sind sie
weniger krebserregend aber immer noch
ein bisschen deswegen sagt die fsh bei
dieser studie
es gibt zwar einen signifikanten trend
aber die ergebnisse deuten nicht darauf
hin dass glyphosat krebs auslöst anders
ist es bei dieser studie die zeigt
erstens ein richtig schönen dosis
wirkungs verlauf also je mehr krise
desto mehr häuser hatten diesen krebs
und das jetzt auch schon bei viel
niedrigeren dosen aber man sieht auch
diese daten passen nicht zu den anderen
studien denn es einen echten effekt gäbe
müsste er da nicht wenigstens
ansatzweise auch bei den anderen studien
auftauchen die fsa schlussfolgert dass
es sich hier um einen zufälligen
kurvenverlauf handeln muss wenn man
viermal mit 21 seitigen würfel würfelt
kann da eben auch mal ne eins dabei sein
also das waren es nur zwei konkrete
beispiele um zu verstehen wie die fsa
statistisch signifikante ergebnisse als
nicht überzeugend einstufen kann die ec
das anders innerhalb der
berücksichtigten studien gab es bei zwei
studien für zwei unterschiedliche
krebsarten jeweils ein erhöhtes risiko
durch glyphosat woraus die er jetzt
schloss das sind hinreichend gute belege
dafür dass glyphosat krebs in mäusen
auslöst es wurden auch noch weitere
studien begutachter zum beispiel ob
glyphosat eine dna schädigen der wirkung
hat es gab dazu auch hinweise unter
anderem in mäusen die aber auch erst
wieder bei extrem hohen dosen auftaucht
die ihr rc schloss daraus ja es gibt
starke belege für eine dna schädigende
wirkung die ehe fans eingehen sagte nein
es liegt an der armut holen dosis die
ist für diese dna schäden verantwortlich
deswegen gesamturteil nein glyphosat
keine dna schädigende wirkung jetzt
wissen wir zell und tierversuche haben
nur eine beschränkte aussagekraft für
uns menschen und wir erinnern uns die
beobachtung schule mit menschen war
nicht aufschlussreich durch die
verschiedenen puzzleteile also zehn
versuche die versuche
beobachtungsstudien geben am ende doch
ein gesamtbild und hier sagt die irc wir
sehen eine dna schädigung wir sehen
krebserregende wirkung quartieren
deswegen ist das was wir in den case
kontroll studien beobachten
wahrscheinlich eine echte erhöhung des
krebsrisikos durchfahrt die fsa sagt sie
sehen keine dna schädigende wirkung wir
sehen keine krebserregende wirkung in
tieren und deswegen ist das was wir in
den case control studien sehen
wahrscheinlich nur auf bei ist es fehler
zurückzuführen wie zum beispiel den
erinnerungs weiß was bei solchen studien
typisch ist also ein genauer blick in
die forschung zeigt muss folgendes dass
die beiden behörden zu unterschiedlichen
ergebnissen kommen ist auf beiden seiten
wissenschaftlich nachvollziehbar und
lässt uns wohl oder übel mit einer
gewissen unsicherheit zurück wobei jetzt
für alltag und praxis schon sagen kann
für die meisten menschen gilt kein grund
zur panik vor allem wegen der
ordentlichen grenzwerte die wir haben
und der geringen mengen denen wir
tatsächlich ausgesetzt sind sie schon
bei aller unsicherheit sollten drei
sachen trotzdem klar sein erstens wir
brauchen mehr studien wir müssen die
gefahrenbewertung immer wieder weiter
aktualisiert
zweitens es geht hier nicht nur um uns
und krebs sondern natürlich auch um die
umwelt aber eins muss uns auch klar sein
ackerbau an sich ist immer ein massiver
eingriff in die natur
ich meine wir machen flächen weise alle
pflanzen platt nur um die pflanzen
anzubauen die wir essen können dass es
nie ein gesundes ökosystem und allein in
dieser hinsicht ist es dann auch egal ob
wir die pflanzen mit pestiziden
entfernen ob wir pflügen ob wir die mit
der hand raus reisen oder ob wir
umwerfer benutzen zumindest die insekten
die jetzt hier wildkräuter oder blüten
suchen werden so oder so keine wir
finden will damit sagen jetzt eine
bestimmte unkrautvernichtung saab
einfach zu verbieten
macht die situation nicht automatisch
besser sinnvoller ist es wenn wir viele
verschiedene werkzeuge zur hand haben
und dann auf basis wissenschaftlicher
kriterien beurteilen welches konzept wo
welche vorteile hat drittens sollte klar
sein diese schwarz weiß ich mit ihr oft
auf dieses thema geschaut wird ist aus
wissenschaftlicher sicht nicht
gerechtfertigt also es ist weder
wissenschaftlich eindeutig belegt dass
glyphosat krebserregend ist noch ist es
unwissenschaftlich diese möglichkeit in
betracht zu ziehen es ist also nicht
immer nur eine frage der zahlen und
fakten sondern immer auch eine frage der
interpretation
auch das ist wissenschaft natürlich
hätte ich euch heute auch lieber eine
klare antwort gegeben aber wenn die
wissenschaft das nun einmal nicht
hergibt dann müssen wir lernen auch mit
solchen unsicherheiten vernünftig
umzugehen und das heißt dass wir nicht
nur irgendwelche spekulationen verfallen
sondern dass wir uns informieren
aufklären und ansonsten erst mal
abwarten und tee trinken
ok hohe marketing meinte schon lange
leer